so the the debate that everyone's having
now the thing everyone's discussing is
it's it's and it's a great debate it's a
very intellectually stimulating debate
it's over the issue of whether or not
Jesus is a socialist the person who runs
the democratic socialists of America
made this claim recently in an interview
and and then former comedian Stephen
Colbert said the same thing on his show
a couple days ago he said that God is a
socialist and he cited as proof the fact
that Jesus didn't charge a copay before
healing blind people so that obviously
indicates that he was a socialist
so alright let's let's tackle this
question was Jesus a socialist and
here's my argument no you nitwits no he
was not a socialist
and if that's it that's the end of the
show we'll just leave it there because I
don't want
it's hardly it's hardly a statement that
that warrants a response because it's so
absurd but I realize that this is a
popular idea even among some Christians
so I guess maybe I should elaborate a
little bit more net so if I had to
elaborate
then this is what this is what I would
say
fact I'll give you three reasons why
Jesus is not a socialist and why this
whole idea is completely ridiculous and
I'm gonna move pretty quickly through
the first two reasons I think there's
sort of self-evident and I want to focus
more on the third so first of all Jesus
did not endorse any economic or
political system at all so that's the
first way we know he wasn't socialist
because he never said anything about
about any kind of government system or
economic system which means that he
wasn't a socialist but he wasn't a
capitalist either to say that Jesus was
a capitalist would also be ridiculous
and you do on occasion hear that you
don't hear that claim nearly as often as
you hear that Jesus was a socialist but
I have heard in response to that Jesus
was a socialist argument I have
sometimes heard people say well no he
was really a capitalist well it wasn't
that either Jesus it's it's very
glaringly obvious when you read
scriptures that or at least the way that
appears is Jesus doesn't really care
that much what's what's economic system
you're you're living under that's not
really his point
and we'll get to his point here in a
minute but he wasn't concerned with that
he wasn't concerned with making these
reforms to political systems that's not
what he was what he was worried about it
could have and in fact I think that
most people in his time expected him to
do that they expected him to come in and
be a political revolutionary and he
wasn't that
and now we have 2000 years of
Christianity and we have we have the
scripture you know that we can go back
and reference to see very clearly that
he was not a political revolutionary yet
yet still somehow even people today are
as surprised and I guess disappointed as
people were back in Jesus's time that he
is not a political revolutionary that's
not what he was about
he was a reason he was is a
revolutionary of a of a very different
more transcendent sort second point
socialism and communism our objective
evils and we know that because we can
look by your fruits you shall know them
so let's look at the fruits of this
particular fig tree and we'll find that
we've got over 100 million people since
the beginning of the 20th century who
have been killed 100 over well over a
hundred million people who have been
killed by communism and socialism and
then many many millions more that have
been left starving destitute imprisoned
enslaved even still today if you look
over in places like Venezuela so that's
that's the effect that communism and
socialism have they they they are a
blight on the earth and it's really
impossible to ignore that fact when you
just look at very recent world history
third point this is what I really want
to focus on
you could almost put the other two aside
even though
even though those two points alone
should be enough to dispel this whole
notion you can even put them aside let's
focus on this third thing most important
the whole idea behind socialism really
is to find a way to solve poverty the
the fact that socialism is a solution
for poverty which only leads to more
poverty should really tell you so tell
you something and it tells us not only
that socialism is a horrible system in
and of itself it tells us that poverty
is not a social disease that the
government can cure and so anytime the
government sets out to cure it to get
rid of it and to instating kind of
utopian society where poverty doesn't
exist anytime the government tries to do
that has disastrous results because it
cannot happen and that's not the way
that Jesus wanted us to look at Jesus
does not want us to address poverty
through bureaucracy that's that's not
the primary way that he wants us to
address it which isn't to say that
government should have no role
whatsoever in helping the poor that's
not the point it's simply to say that
the responsibility of helping the less
fortunate falls primarily on the
individual not primarily on the state
I think that it's clear that that's the
that's the practically speaking that's
the best way of going about it but also
from a spiritual perspective from a
religious from a Christian perspective
that is obviously what Jesus believed as
well so I've we kind of been through
these verses before another discussing
other topics but let's go through them
again because they're very relevant to
this topic too so here's a few verses I
think we should look at
instances in scripture where Jesus is
talking about the poor and what we're
supposed to do about the poor this is
it's obviously a topic he talked quite a
bit uh talked about quite a bit so if he
really wanted us to in-state some
particular economic system in order to
help poor people he had plenty of
opportunity to mention it and he never
did but this is what he said instead
Matthew 25:40 and the king will answer
them truly I say to you as you did it to
one of the least of these brothers you
did it to me Matthew 5:40 to give to the
one who begs from you and do not refuse
the one who would borrow from you Luke
12 33 sell your possessions and give it
to the needy provide yourselves with
moneybags that do not grow old with a
treasure in the heavens that does not
fail where no thief approaches and no
moth destroys for where your treasure is
there will your heart be also
Luke 21 1 Jesus looked up and saw the
rich putting their gifts into the
offering box and he saw a poor Widow put
in the two small put in two small copper
coins and he said truly I tell you this
poor widow has put in more than all of
them for they all contributed out of
their abundance but she out of her
poverty put in all she had to live on
Luke 1412 he said also to the man who
had invited him when you give a dinner
or a banquet do not invite your friends
or your brothers or your relatives or
rich neighbors lest they also invite you
in return and you'll be repaid but when
you give a feast invite the poor the
crippled the lame the blind and you will
be blessed because they cannot repay you
for you will be repaid at the
resurrection of the just Luke 3:11 and
he answered them whoever has two tunics
is to share with him who has none and
whoever has food is to do likewise
so just a few examples five or six
examples they're talking about the poor
notice
that the words governments state law
policy tax
least of all socialism do not appear in
any of these verses
here is Jesus over and over and over
again talking about here's what we
should do about poor people he never
says anything about about passing a law
never even mensen mentions it it's
pretty incredible right but there is a
word that appears over 20 times in just
those five or six versions that is the
word you
over and over again exciting you you
this is what you need to do you
personally this is what you personally
as an individual should be doing
Jesus is not interested in establishing
systems by which the poverty problem can
be in personally solved he's interested
in you going by your own free will with
your own money and taking all of that
and using it to help your neighbor
he wants you to take your money
and give it to the needy in your
community that's what he wants
and I don't think that and this is I'm
not putting words in Jesus's mouth I'm
not I'm not not even really interpreting
those passages that's what he's saying
very directly this is what you need to
do
and I don't think that that obligation
is fulfilled I don't think it even
begins to be fulfilled by paying your
taxes now he also tells us to pay our
taxes but I don't think he does not
complete paying your taxes with helping
the poor those two things are not
related in fact he says give the Caesar
what is Caesar's those will be the taxes
but in terms of your in your possessions
your tunic your your food your you know
your individual possessions give those
to the poor
so though those two obligations are not
the same and I I would also mention that
our obligation help the poor is
especially not fulfilled by sitting on
the side and lobbying the government to
take more money from your neighbor to
give to the poor which is it's it's very
interesting that's so often the people
who are pushing for these systems that's
what they want they're not even saying
take more for me they're saying no take
more from all of those people all of
these socialist college students for
instance who have no job no assets
nothing to tax yet they want more they
want they want things for themselves too
right they want they want their student
loans paid for they want all that stuff
but then they also are socialists right
they're social so they're saying they're
saying give some stuff to me oh yeah it
also give to the poor but don't take
from me take from those guys over take
from those guys and then give a little
bit to me to pay off my student and then
also give some to the poor aren't I so
generous I'm so generous that I am
lobbying for the government to take more
from those guys and give it to those
guys
no that wasn't what Jesus had in mind
there's also really interesting thing in
scripture that you notice and I think we
often kind of gloss over and that is
that Jesus tells us constantly to give
to the poor
yet he also says that he also says
blessed are the poor he warns us against
wealth tells us to give up everything
tells us to give up our attachment to
worldly possessions tells us to give our
wealth to the poor who he says are
blessed because they don't have that
wealth
and who it seems could possibly be
harmed by wealth because he obviously
says that wealth is a is a dangerous
thing
because it can lead you to an attachment
to the world and away from eternal life
so all those things are kind of
confusing isn't it
and notice something else too I
mentioned that the there was the story
of the of the widow and the temple gives
her gives her only two coins to the
temple and Jesus points to her as an
example and commends her but if the
point here is just to kind of get rid of
poverty like it's some kind of disease
to treat it to cure it like a disease
then wouldn't he have told the widow no
no no don't you're poor already no nope
don't put your last two coins in the no
don't do that don't put those in the
Treasury take those wouldn't you have
told her to take her coins out and then
told one of the rich folks to put in two
more coins to compensate but he doesn't
do that
why
I think these are questions we have to
tackle and when we do it becomes it
becomes kind of obvious
that the real point here jesus's real
point is love what Jesus wants us to do
what he wants from us is love
and that's the real point of giving to
the poor is is his love is loving them
obviously providing for their physical
needs is important and it's part of the
point but it's not the primary point the
primary point is to love them to lift
them up to elevate them through this act
of personal self-sacrificing love
and so through when you by your own free
will and volition make the choice to go
and help somebody help someone who's
less fortunate
then you obviously what you're doing
whatever practical thing you're doing
for them if you're giving the mood food
if you're giving them money then there
are some very real practical benefits
there because those are things that they
need physically so that's great
but even more important in that they are
lifted up by this humanizing love that
you're showing for them and then you are
also lifted up by you you also benefit
from this act of love
now the problem is
and as I said I'm not suggesting that
the government has absolutely no role
whatsoever ever in
providing some form of assistance for
some people I'm not saying that but what
we have to deal with is the fact that
there is no love in the welfare state
there is no love in taxation
it's bureaucratic it's impersonal it's
disinterested it's dehumanizing
someone a poor person does not
experience and is not elevated by the
fruits of love when he cashes a check
that was sent to him by some government
office
as any as anyone ever felt this the
power of love would bye-bye when they're
given an EBT card
is that is that is that is that our
people lift it up by this feeling of
love from the from the bureaucratic
entity that handed them this card no I
think I think what what happens is that
it's sort of the opposite that poor
people are treated like numbers and
statistics they are treated like a
problem that must be solved they are not
treated like human beings who must be
loved
so we're doing the opposite of what
Christ tells us to do when we neglect
the poor in our own communities and
trust that the government will just take
care of it even if the government's
taking care of it with our own money and
so we feel like well that's that's kind
of the same they're using my money and
so it's sort of generous no that's not
no no paying your taxes as you are
compelled to do in which you have no
choice but to do is not love
cheering on the entitlement system
funded mostly with other people's money
not your own that is not love
I think to love is to go on your own
personally and to give to give what you
have to give of yourself that's what
we're supposed to do and
even though Jesus does not endorse or
support or advocate for any particular
economic or political system seems clear
to me that an economic or political
system that better enables us to use our
own money and help those in our
community but that is clearly going to
be the superior system
not just from economic and political
standards but from Christian standards
because it better enables us to do what
Jesus is telling us to do
I mean this is something that is
especially been on my heart the last
year or so because you think about even
um you know when you're when you're
walking downtown in the city and you
pass by all these homeless people and
there's always that you pass by a
homeless person there's always that
that feeling of discomfort and you feel
a little weary like you want to give the
money but then you also realize that
that a great majority of homeless people
have drug and alcohol problems it's why
they're homeless many of them and so if
you give them money it seems like
there's probably a very good statistical
chance that they're gonna use it on
drugs or alcohol and so there's so
there's always that should I give them
money should not get to just passed by a
homeless person to give them nothing
feels cruel but to give them something
that might then be used on drugs or
alcohol maybe that doesn't seem like the
right thing either
and so I think like most people I've all
I've got something that's always been
I'm always going back and forth on that
and and I do think that and I try to
whenever possible I think the best thing
when you see a homeless person if you
can buy him a meal you know give them
food I try I try to keep like little
care packages in my car just bags of it
was just toiletries and snacks and maybe
a gift cards to some fast food place or
something so that if I do see almost
person I can give them that which i
think is is of course better than than
money
but
recently I realized let's say I don't
have a care package to give them let's
say I can't I don't have time to go get
them a meal and you know recently I
would I the last year or so what I've
come to realize personally is that you
passed by a homeless person just even
you know even if you have a couple
dollars just give them something and
yeah you don't know what they're gonna
do with the money that could go use it
on drugs or alcohol and that would be
unfortunate but
just give him some money anyway even if
it's just a dollar because the the point
really isn't the money itself and the
point isn't even really what they spend
it on although you hope they spend it on
something that they actually need and
not something that's gonna further
destroy them physically but the point is
just to say to this person who is
forgotten and neglected by society and
it was living on the street and who has
been just living in this inhuman
situation the point is just to say to
them I noticed you and you're a human
being and so yeah I got some money in my
pocket let me give it to you
like I was gonna go use this money on a
coffee I'll give it to you because your
person you're human like I am and so I'm
noticing you
and I've come to realize that that's
more the point so just as a personal
thing I
I try to
tried to resolve that I'll never pass by
almost person without giving them
something just just so they're being
noticed as a as a person because I think
that is humanizing and that and that
lifts them up and I think that's the
point that's what we should do
and the more of our own money that we
have at our disposal then the more able
we are to go and help others
and then it's kind of the best of both
worlds all right thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed